shoes
hi I'm Sushi Huang I'm an associate
professor of marketing at Stanford
Business School before my academic
career I worked at JWT Advertising
agency managing Asian Pacific markets
taught many courses at Stanford and a
topic that excites me the most is
Behavioral Science the human factor
there's so much to learn about how
humans make decisions how humans get
motivated and how humans connect with
others I have five key takeaways from
the human factor to share with you today
[Music]
As Leaders we tend to rely on data for
our decisions and we think that other
people also will be motivated by the
same data as it turns out most of our
stakeholders are drawn to examples
Salient top of my example to become the
guiding principles for their decision
making
that is why people buy lottery tickets
even though the actual probability of
winning lottery is extremely low we were
made to remember the examples of people
winning the lottery much more so than
thinking about the overwhelming examples
of people who don't win so brainstorm
ways to make your company's messages the
lottery in your stakeholders mind
[Music]
traditional thinkers we see pros and
cons in everything and keep engaged to
define the best choice but for many
other people these pros and cons are
ambiguous therefore every time they
choose they feel that they are losing
something decisions are hard for them
and there is always a trade-off
create a win-win option in the set
leverage default selection
reference points can be used to make the
choice easier
these elements help to resolve decision
difficulty and make it easier for your
stakeholders to come to conclusions
[Music]
Recent research has shown that while
star ratings can predict the success of
books blockbuster movies and restaurants
it is the emotionality underlying the
reviews that explain these sales results
in other words not all 5 star ratings
are the same the ones with higher
positive emotionality will lead to
Greater success and vice versa for
reviews that have strong negative
emotionality in them
therefore Infuse your messages with
emotion
the more emotional people can get about
your product and your company the more
likely they will be motivated to stay
with you through ups and downs
we not only think about how we
personally feel about a decision we also
care a lot about how others think about
these decisions social influences are
extremely powerful and that is why we
buy products to keep up with our peers
we follow so-called experts advice and
we watch TV shows that are rated well by
others even when these others are
strangers too
successful leaders know how to leverage
social forces so that people can be
confident in their decisions and even
become ambassadors for the brand it is
good to know that a decision is accurate
but it is even more important to know
that others think that the decision is
accurate
[Music]
do not live in a vacuum there is always
a context the context of our environment
activates important goals which shape
our behaviors
by taking people from One complex to
another we can therefore change the key
drivers of their decision the context
can be one the physical environment such
as moving from your office to your home
second the cultural surroundings
how many of us have moved from one
country to another
three a social contact
and four the temporal compact
my research has shown that sales teams
behave very differently in the beginning
of the months compared to the end of the
month as they get closer to their sales
goals
that is a powerful change in their
temporal male packs staying static will
make you ineffective successful leaders
are Nimble because they understand how
critical context is and how fast it can
change we can all become more effective
leaders and communicators
the knowledge of the human factor can be
learned and with practice we become
better at leveraging these ideas when I
moved from Taiwan to the United States
and from industry to Academia I realized
that the Salient examples are different
here when people get emotional about is
different and the social elements and
the context are all completely different
so I had to relearn how I communicate
how I teach and how I lead it is
certainly a challenge but it has also
been a very fun and fulfilling Journey
[Music]
as a kid I did not like school that much
I did not really like doing homework or
taking exams so definitely I surprised
myself by joining Academia but I think
it evolved because at some point I
started getting curious and I realized
knowledge is powerful so that guided me
back to Academia to learn more to get a
PhD and to become a professor so I can
share the knowledge I learned with you
all
[Music]